a lot of people come up to me and they
say Conan how did you get to be such a
great talk show host it's it's happened
like twice anyway there are lots of
stories online about how I got started
but I want to tell you none of them are
true
now that we are at comic-con I think
it's time I told you my real origin
story
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm sorry that's the story of the time I
found that quarter I loved that quarter
I remember now let's show my real origin
story did you enjoy the show Conan
I loved it mother excuse me dr. Thomas
and Martha Wayne no were the O'Briens
he's looking for Bruce Wayne's mom and
dad were in that alley Thanks
[Applause]
again I apologize that's the story of
how I got Bruce Wayne's parents killed I
remember it now this finally is my
origin story standing by to detonate sir
you sure there's nobody out there you'll
be around for 200 miles sir
alright then on my 103
[Music]
doc what happened there's some good news
and some bad news young man what's the
bad news
it's your hair it's permanently stuck
that way I'm a freak
what's the good news you were stuck in
the blast zone of an experimental
hilarity balm hilarity balm that's right
you were exposed to massive doses of
humor rays and chortle beams you are now
approximately 5,000 times funnier than
louis c.k and Amy Schumer combined my
mother-in-law stuck a butter knife in a
light socket
she really lights up a room
that day a new man was born I would no
longer go by the name chip Whitley from
that day forward I would be Conan
O'Brien
[Applause]
hey come on that is complete horseshit
you were working on The Simpsons and
then Letterman left and you just
auditioned to take his job yeah that's
yeah that's right I was yeah I was on
The Simpsons and then I yeah but the
point is you're right Andy but still
either way I became
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please